good morning the picture in afghanistan
is changing almost by the hour a
developing story that has huge global
consequences 600 british troops have
been sent to the country to help get to
uh uk nationals out of that country tell
me more about this story in just a
second the taliban though has captured
kandahar the country's second biggest
city as well as lush gagar the capital
of hellman province in a few moments
time we'll speak to the defense
secretary ben wallace and we'll have
more throughout the morning here on sky
news but first let me tell you more
about what's happening in plymouth uh
six people confirmed dead including the
suspected gunman he has died in a
shooting in the city as well devon and
cornwall police were called to biddick
drive in the kiam area at about 10 past
six last night police said three females
two males and the suspect died the local
mp says one of the victims was under the
age of 10. from plymouth ashna huinag
reports
[Applause]
it was just after six last night that
police paramedics and air ambulances
were called to kiam in plymouth
eyewitnesses say they heard the sound of
gunshots
police have now confirmed six are dead
two women and three men one of whom is
believed to be the shooter
it's been a pretty grim evening for
everyone in kiam and in plymouth as the
local mp posted this update on twitter
the home secretary said her thoughts are
with those affected she said she has
spoken to the chief constable to offer
her full support she urged everyone to
remain calm follow police advice and
allow our emergency services to get on
with their jobs
so all happened in the area
the shooting happened on biddick drive a
residential estate in plymouth
obviously it's quite close to home so
which is quite frightening so yeah
scary it's not really what you think to
hear darwin and plymouth is it really
it's just uh
i know the ordinary the labour leader
said there's so much we don't know about
the shocking events in plymouth but said
it's clear tragedy has hit kiam
locals say the area is now eerily quiet
as police investigate an incident they
say is contained but critical
ashna is with us now in plymouth this
morning hello to ashna my goodness me
six people dead we don't really know
much more at this stage
are the police gonna fill us in more
later on
that is the hope okay the latest that we
have from devon and cornwall police is
this is being is not being treated as a
terror-related incident is being treated
as a domestic one they are not searching
for anyone else in relation to
their investigation at the moment and at
the moment we know that everyone
involved all of those people who have
perished all of their family members
have been informed this has been
described as a devastating incident for
the city of plymouth i'm standing at the
entrance to buddhic drive just beyond
the mound uh behind me that is the
estate itself we know the officers have
been there throughout the night
and within the last hour we actually saw
a coroner's ambulance going up that
drive behind me and police presence is
likely to continue throughout the day of
course later we are going to likely see
forensics teams makes making their way
down here and continuing their
investigations when officers were called
here just after six yesterday evening
they were responding to calls from the
public who said they were hearing
gunshots when they arrived they found
two women and two men had died at the
scene they also found another woman who
they took to hospital and she also later
died from her injuries you know all of
the six people uh died from gunshot
wounds and it includes the suspected
gunman himself as i've said before it's
not known what the motives are at this
stage but it is certainly been described
as a tragedy for this area
we'll come back to you later on in the
programme for now thank you
our other main story this morning
600 uk troops are being sent to
afghanistan to help british nationals
leave the country following the rapid
advance of the taliban afghanistan's
second city kandahar has now fallen as
well as lashkar the capital of helmand
province thousands of people are fleeing
the fighting and seeking sanctuary in
kabul as our chief correspondent stuart
ramsey reports now from the afghan
capital
where they can find a space they huddle
in family groups
every day more and more people are
arriving here carrying whatever
possessions they could gather together
before fleeing the fighting that is
raging across afghanistan
it's as far as turning into a major
humanitarian crisis the numbers of
displaced people grow by the day even
the hour
the lightning offensive of the taliban
on cities in the north south east and
west of the country is simply
overwhelming afghanistan's army and its
government
farida kurasani's husband and brother
both police officers were killed by the
taliban in kunduz
they were attacked in their police
station
she escaped to kabul with her two
children
she has nothing now
she feels failed by everyone do you
think the americans leaving has caused
this problem
a day ago
joining 1800 families in this park
in afghanistan that's over twelve and a
half thousand people just in this park
it's already miserable it'll definitely
get worse
these families have escaped the fighting
for now but they are not safe the
taliban are creeping closer and closer
to the capital the real impression you
get here is that people feel that karma
is being surrounded or it's certainly
going to be in the coming weeks and of
course the situation's going to get
worse food prices are already going up
petrol prices
have gone up as well and there'll be
more displaced people arriving here
and there seems nothing at this stage
obvious at least that's going to see the
taliban stopped in their tracks
on the face of it kabul seems pretty
much as normal the traffic clogged up
because huge sections of the city are
closed and barricaded from potential
suicide attacks
20 years and trillions of dollars spent
attempting to defeat the taliban and
build a democracy here appears to have
been a mission on the verge of total
abject failure
stuart ramsey sky news kabul
mean time looking at some of the other
stories making headlines for you this
morning
and britney spears father has agreed to
step down as her conservator but only
when he feels the time is right he says
the singer's lawyer has described jamie
spears decision as vindication and a
major victory for her
more than one in ten uk patients were
infected with coronavirus during the
first wave of the pandemic while being
treated in hospital for something else
writing in the lancet researchers say
the findings need to be urgently looked
at to ensure lessons are learnt
officials in turkey say the number of
people killed in severe flooding and
mudslides in the north of the country
has now reached 27. search and rescue
crews recovered a further ten bodies
overnight in one of the worst-hit
provinces hundreds have been safely
rescued by helicopters but an
eight-year-old woman was reported
missing in barton province
about this time when we show you our
climate dashboard uh climate change on
the planet top line
is uh how much uh fuel we're using in
which capacity the one below that is how
hot we are compared to 18 81.2 degrees
up from 1880 below that is when
scientists expect us to get to 1.5
degrees celsius above the temperatures
in 1880 and below that the carbon
dioxide emissions
pleased to say the defense secretary ben
wallace can join us now mr wallace i
know that you have a very very big busy
day ahead of you so thank you for taking
the time a couple of operational
questions to start with uh if you can
indulge us as much as you can and then
perhaps we can talk about the politics
after that uh british troops um arriving
in afghanistan
what is their role is it a rescue
mission
no it it
we are withdrawing we we made that some
months ago clear and the timetable we're
working to is obviously the american
announced timetable of september the
11th there was always going to be a
phase where you effectively put in
logisticians air movers
command and control personnel and
a force to protect that force
and that is the appropriate moment is to
do that now so that is approximately 600
extra people will be going in the first
elements will be going in by the end of
the week
and their job is to make sure that we
can continue to process the afghan
interpreters and the wider community
that we have an obligation to
help draw down
some of those people from the embassy
that are going to come out as we reduce
that footprint and then lastly a group
of what we call entitled personnel those
are people who are have british passport
holders there is a theoretical number uh
you know those are people such as
security guards who might be working for
aid agencies or indeed just british
passport holders that we have an
obligation to bring out that requires
central brits are coming home
yes that's exactly right that could be
up to up to 3 000 people okay um
kandahar and lashkar is it your
understanding that both have fallen
yes they pretty much now in the hands of
the taliban
as as we speak kandahar not so much but
obviously
as well yes
um home to camp bastian of course uh
where so many british troops were based
at the time how big a mistake was it uh
for the brits to withdraw from
afghanistan in the manner in which we
did
well
first of all we haven't withdrawn at the
moment but i know what you're trying to
say look
i was public about it that at the time
of the trump deal with obviously the
taliban i felt that that was a mistake
to have done it that way that
you know we'll all as an international
community probably pay the consequences
of that
but you know when the united states as
the framework nation took that decision
the way we were all configured where we
had gone in uh meant that we had to
leave as well and you know that that is
a strategic decision that has been made
though it is the case you know for 20
years we effectively bought peace on our
streets because al-qaeda was unable to
launch plots from afghanistan and the
way it had
and we had obviously invested in in
education and support for the afghan
government but you know i i have been
pretty blunt about it publicly and
that's quite a rare thing when it comes
to united states decision but
strategically it causes a lot of
problems and i think as an international
community it's very difficult for what
we're seeing today indeed so what
message does it send what message do our
actions does britain send to our allies
in asia in africa and in the middle east
tom tuggenheart you'll know chair of the
foreign affairs committee for the
benefit of our viewers says it shows the
world that we are not to be trusted as a
nation
well i think it's about trust i think
what it is about is that these sorts of
problems around the world
have to be managed you know you can't
just fly in fix something and then
expect it all to be fine and they have
to be managed and management for
countries like afghanistan is not one
year or five years or even 20 years it's
a long long-term commitment and i think
that is that is one of the lessons i
mean the other lesson that the taliban
learned was that if you use your country
to attack another country
just because uh you know you you have
other issues going on it won't stop you
yourself being necessarily removed or
indeed uh people will take a response to
you and britain will always retain that
capability if if if the taliban decide
to go back to what they used to do
and host al-qaeda then of course the
international community have a range of
steps that they can take but you know i
i think this is not just about britain
this is this is the key well you know we
are a military we have a military power
we saw what happened in 2001
and people forget in 2001 there were two
military operations there was the
operation that went in to take out
al-qaeda
and remove parts of the taliban from
power because of 9 11. and that was done
pretty swiftly and pretty quickly and
then of course there was the nato
mission and that the follow-on mission
which was about stabilization and uh
international development
the first authorized operations was a
success and ultimately ended in the
death of osama bin laden
um but i think i think you know and
we'll retain that but i think the lesson
here is also it's not just about britain
it's really easy for for people to make
the narrative that britain has let down
afghanistan if you're going to go to
afghanistan it was very very clear that
you had to go as an international
community and the reason you have to do
that is it's not just about military
power it's about political power it's
about soft power
you know i i've seen a number of people
saying oh britain can't do it we could
send 10 000 troops tomorrow morning and
we could we could deploy them for a
couple of years probably in afghanistan
but if you're on your own
if you're on your own you you won't get
the political leverage of the
neighboring countries that you need you
won't be able to
effectively defend your position by
saying to the taliban or whoever it else
is this is the international community
concerned
and there are lots of things to be done
to put it right if you are purely a
country on your own the soviet union for
example you then face a different
consequence okay so while that diplomacy
i'm sure will be reignited with the
united states given what we're seeing
hour-by-hour unfolding in afghanistan
meantime for now we have left behind a
humanitarian crisis uh general nick
carter chief of the defence staff has
said women are being brutalized forced
marriages to taliban fighters executions
in the streets how can we today tomorrow
when those troops get there start to try
to prevent that crisis becoming a
catastrophe
well i think that's why i as i said
earlier i think that deal that was done
in doha was a rotten deal i'm on the
record of saying because what it
effectively told it told a taliban that
wasn't winning that they were winning
and it undermined the government of
afghanistan and and now we're in this
position where the taliban have clearly
the momentum
across the country and
instead of the political process working
which of course if you remember was what
the doha agreement was supposed to do
and general nick carter was very clear
and correct in pointing out that what
the political part of taliban was saying
what's going on in the ground are not
matching uh and so we are in a difficult
position you know we we've you know the
united states are leaving that was
announced yesterday we are leaving
alongside them
and that leaves a
as you say a very very big problem on
the ground uh developing with the
taliban
obviously with the momentum and it's not
what we probably would have liked not
what we wanted i did try i did try after
the announcement to see if we could
bring together the international
community
and i'm afraid most international
community weren't particularly
interested so defense secretary are you
saying what's happening at the moment
falls to the americans
no it doesn't in the end
you know
the afghans we have put billions of
pounds in 20 years we have sacrificed
lives
lots of money lots of investment in
education three million girls educated
at school
in the end
you know after 20 years it is a
perfectly legitimate question to ask
when can afghan govern themselves it's
quite important
not now not at the moment is the answer
and the situation is as such that a
humanitarian crisis if nothing else
provides a breeding ground for uh
terrorist entities to re-establish we
remember of course that afghanistan was
the country that brought us 911
so for people watching this morning who
think this is something happening in a
country a long long way away we saw what
what can happen when these people become
disenfranchised and they send their
terrorists to our streets to kill
british people what's our plan b to try
to make sure that doesn't happen
well uh from a purely military point of
view we have capabilities that we can
bring to bear
from outside into a country if we have
uh the right to do so and and we do have
a right if britain is under an imminent
threat or people are plotting uh in
another country and that country won't
take action under international law we
have the ability to do something about
that we do that uh often or all over the
world we do it in certain parts of the
world another failed states
people will cover uh issues around i i
make a
periodic announcements about strikes we
make on isis in places like uh syria and
iraq that's at the same time afghanistan
at the moment you're not worried that
that could be a scenario as a result of
what's happening there at the moment
i'm absolutely worried that failed
states breed uh bri our breeding grounds
for those type of people of course i'm
worried it's why i said you know i felt
this was not the right time or decision
to make because of course
al qaeda will probably come back i
certainly would would like that type of
breeding ground that is what we see
failed states around the world lead to
instability
and lead to a security a threat to us
and our interests we we're very clear
about that that's why the west has to
learn that you don't fix problems you
manage problems you know you you have to
you know go into a country if that's
what you're going to do and you manage
it there's no such thing as an instant
fix which i think
it you know is one of the differences
between the west and many parts of the
world
and that's what happened but yes i'm
concerned but we do have capabilities to
protect ourselves even after leaving
afghanistan okay defense actually we're
an hour out of time i've got another
couple of questions for you if i may
lord dana the former chief of the
general staff says reversing the cut in
foreign aid
would help last year to afghanistan it
was 167.5 million this year just looked
it up this morning 37.5 million a cut of
78 in foreign aid to afghanistan that
would certainly help with any
humanitarian crisis is that something
that the british government should
reconsider
i think the british government's been
clear that the cut has been a temporary
cut but also you know let's not forget
foreign aid is part of it but remember
defense delivers huge amounts of what we
call soft power we recently had a team
in sudan building a dam for example my
soldiers in in my department are
constantly around the world doing
humanitarian support not not pure
military support so you know there are
there are a lot of ways to deliver that
uh support but you know one of the
challenges now will be in afghanistan
delivering aid you know are we going to
have to check the taliban in future uh
especially and that's something that
taliban seem to have
discarded which is they were clearly
desperate for international recognition
when they made those choices uh to
to allegedly do this deal um but you
know you don't get international
recognition if you are committing those
atrocities and the like that we've seen
uh being reported so okay the new
challenge is how do we deliberate okay
two two uh very quick questions about
stories at home um gurkhas on the
streets of whitehall you know that they
are starving themselves to death they
say because they want to have a meeting
with you about their pensions
what should we do about it
well first of all that group of people
i'm very happy to meet any gurkha my
father fought alongside the gurkhas and
malaya in the 1950s so uh you know uh it
is a pretty uh remarkable group of
people the the group of people currently
protesting are groups affected uh by the
change by the labor government in 1997
2003
this was about people who were under a
1947 pension it's a very small group of
pensioners they they had different
advantages in their pension scheme in
that old scheme that scheme said that
you got it after 15 years when a british
soldier got off to 22
but there is a difference and and they
feel that that difference needs to be
made up it's been a long-running uh
position of that group that's not the
same as the gurkhas of today or the
gurkhas after 2003 they get exactly the
same pensions as british serving
personnel but of course no government of
any cover labor or conservative or
coalition has ever retrospectively
changed pensions that okay that's not
been the case defense secretary i know
that well you said that you you'd be
willing to meet them i'm sure that that
will probably help that situation so
thank you for the clarification on that
before i let you go the situation in
plymouth this morning
look uh it's a tragedy uh what's
happened there um the police are having
another significant meeting this morning
we can rule out terrorism uh from that
event
and i think it it all it does it goes to
underline the importance of issues such
as gun control but also uh you know
what's happening in people's homes up
and down the country 34 million our
local police forces so they could be
better armed to deal with it but overall
my thoughts are with the tragic uh loss
of life and the the people who you know
families who've lost loved ones today uh
the police have resolved the situation
is my understanding and we can rule out
terrorism
indeed defense secretary a challenging
few days ahead for you we appreciate you
taking the time to join us this morning
thank you
bye-bye
thank you
at least correspondent alistair bunkel
is with us now um hello to you alistair
good morning to you so the defence
secretary is saying
i warned that this might happen
yeah i think ben wallace i mean he's got
a difficult line to tread because he is
the defense secretary he needs to
maintain some sort of diplomatic dignity
with allies nato and the united states
of course but he is clearly particularly
a former soldier himself uh pretty angry
at what's going on he is surrounded in
the ministry of defense by uh men and
women who would have served in
afghanistan who will have seen the cost
of serving in afghanistan and will be
watching what is going on now and
wondering what it was all for
and he
ben wallace that is uh i think clearly
does not think that the withdrawal and
the nature of the withdrawal was the
right thing to do nevertheless uh we are
where we are now uh and i'm afraid it
looks both depressing and a complete
inevitability uh the taliban are taking
district capitals and major uh urban
hubs you know almost every couple of
hours now kandahar and lash gagar
falling overnight both of those will be
uh familiar names to many viewers
because lashkar was the headquarters of
the british mission in helmand province
kandahar a major city in the south as
well where a lot of the raf were based
for a time flying missions out of there
and now we look to the capital kabul
it'll be interesting to see what the
taliban strategy is i think it'll be a
whole different ball game trying to
retake
kabul but it looks as though uh that
will be a fight that is possibly only
weeks away now
thank you
i want to return now obviously we'll
continue covering what's happening in
afghanistan throughout the course of the
programme it looks like lashkar has also
fallen to the taliban this morning as
well as kandahar uh the latest we're
hearing from our man on the ground in
kabul is that
within the next 30 days it does appear
that the capital cabal will be
surrounded by the taliban
more on that to come as i said but first
let's get some more on the mass shooting
in plymouth now where police have
confirmed six people including the
suspect have died
joining us now is dr tim parsons senior
lecturer of policing and criminology and
former chief inspector of the city of
london police he's joining us from
plymouth hello to you good morning to
you your reaction to what's happened in
plymouth
well obviously it's uh it's an
absolutely tragic uh incident and uh i'm
sure it'd be extremely distressing for
um members of the local community
i'm sure that's absolutely the case
one wonders about um how someone can get
a gun and shoot six people
just after tea time in
an area like plymouth the police have to
react very quickly they're told that
there are gunshots and they run towards
danger when so many of us are running
away how does the police deal with that
sort of situation what goes into effect
immediately
so devon and cornwall police like like
every force in the uk it's got a
highly trained and well-equipped
tactical firearms unit
their armed response vehicles are a
regular site onto the streets
so i'm sure they would have deployed
firearms officers very quickly to the
scene where they would have tried to
cordon off the
affected area and then tried to contain
the situation
and my understanding is that the other
emergency services also attended very
quickly but important to manage the
expectations as well of the local people
who
have you know they know six people are
dead uh outside their front door how do
how do the police start to manage those
expectations
yes well absolutely and and of course
all sorts of other police resources will
be put into place to to try and deal
with the uh with the trauma
um to um to help and assist the the
family members of the of the victims
there's a huge amount of support that
can be deployed to uh to manage that
um and police and other services are
well equipped and well experienced to uh
to deal with that
how do you foresee the investigation uh
moving on from here
well obviously the full facts and
circumstances uh need to be and will be
investigated i mean there's fairly
limited information in the public domain
at the moment i mean police will be
looking at obviously
the firearm what sort of firearm it was
um how it came to be in this person's
possession was it a
legally owned firearm
or had it been stolen or acquired uh in
another sort of illegal fashion
um and
as i say you know eventually all that
will will become available in a public
domain
okay good to talk to you thanks for your
expertise this morning appreciated thank
you
six people have been killed on the
streets of plymouth overnight we're
expecting to hear from the police at
some stage during the course of the
programme this morning and we will
update you as soon as we can meantime
look at the weather here's kirsty kirsty
good morning
good morning kay it looks as though the
weather's a little bit more promising
today for parts of the uk and ireland a
little bit more in the way of drier
brighter weather but there are still
some showers to watch out for
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
no sign of a heat wave just yet across
the uk and ireland but there will be
some warm spells of sunshine today still
some showers around especially for much
of scotland parts of northern ireland
too some of the showers will be rather
heavy and blustery could be a few
showers too across parts of the
southwest there you can see a few
drizzly ones around generally speaking
eastern areas staying largely dry just a
small chance of a shower so the focus
tends to be across northwest scotland
where they will be still quite heavy and
blustery with quite brisk winds although
it's not as windy as yesterday now out
of the breeze in the southeast 23 or 24
should feel fairly warm in the sunshine
so some drier weather today the showers
in the north continuing through the
night tonight we also have some wet
weather moving in across ireland later
in the night and a few spots for the
southwest and that will move eastwards
on saturday
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
more reaction to the situation in
plymouth now confirmed that six people
who have died in an incident around
about 10 past six last night johnny goes
now is the mp for plymouth more um and
that's
plymouth more view i should say that's
uh johnny mercer hello to you mr moser
thanks for joining us on the program i
think yours is the neighboring
constituency to this one what do you
know about what happened and what would
you like to say to the people of
plymouth this morning
good morning kay yeah largely just what
is in the what is in the public domain
at the moment we've uh suffered a an
appalling incident of violence um it is
not ongoing
um the police
have dealt with what happened yesterday
and now clearly there is a lot of work
to do to support communities who who
watched and saw some horrific incidents
unfolding on their doorsteps
yesterday
there's families at the center of all of
this and we'll do everything we can to
pull together as a city to support those
who need it and
deal with what is you know one of our
darkest days for many many years
what was your reaction when you uh heard
the news as it started to unfold the
fact that six people have been shot
including the gunman we believe we're
waiting to hear more from the police and
potentially a ten-year-old child
i think it's a devastating incident it
is
it's an appalling act of violence um it
is uh it will have uh uh far-reaching
effects throughout the community which
is very tight-knit down there in kiev
i've been in touch with luke pollard the
local mp will uh opening up a school and
a church this morning for people to come
together victim supports have moved in
um and i'm just
you know
clearly i'm thinking of the families
but also the emergency services who you
know some details will i'm sure come out
um today about this um who've dealt with
a a horrific
situation um something that i know
everybody says it but you just don't
expect it to happen in
in plymouth um and uh we need to pull
together now try and understand why it's
happened
and reassure the local community as much
as we can okay talk to me about um
plymouth what sort of city is it
oh his best city in the uk it's
an amazing uh place between the ocean
and the moor um but better than that our
people are just extraordinary uh it is
clearly a heavily militarily scened
city but there's an awful lot there past
that we've seen the growth of
amazing small businesses that have
become the backbone of the city and
employ employ thousands of people you
know since the the sort of reduction in
numbers at the dockyard
and it's growing it's growing
it's a deeply special place and you just
you know incidents like this you do not
expect um
it is you know they are incredibly rare
um
it would appear to uh to be um you know
contained within
a you know a group of people um but
nonetheless the tragedy is is
far-reaching particularly you know the
details you have some of them this
morning
as they come out later on today um are
heartbreaking for many many individuals
across the city and we'll do everything
we can to support our brilliant people
at this time may i ask you quickly
before i let you go you've seen the
developing situation in afghanistan
overnight we've seen that kandahar has
fallen
where i'm sure you were based given that
you did three tours i think of
afghanistan cambastian part of
lashkargar province
your thoughts this morning
i think it's a tragedy it's appalling um
i think uh the way the
international community but particularly
the uk and the us have
pulled the rug from the afghan security
forces in this way
uh is is humiliating uh and
it is very very difficult for those of
us who committed a long time of
our lives but particularly those who
lost people over there um you know to to
watch this happening and to see
you know so so little comment from
uh our political leaders at this time i
think uh
it is uh it's heartbreaking to watch and
um
you know for we will reap the the
repercussions of this for many years to
come
and i'm deeply sorry for the people of
afghanistan for those who lost loved
ones over there
to watch them over running lashkar now
and places like that where we you know
we fought and
lost people forwards um you know we
never knew it was never going to be a
picnic it was never it was never going
to be the uk
but to to leave the afghan security
forces like this is uh
disgraceful and pretty humiliating for
this country
johnny master thank you for taking the
time to speak to us this morning thank
you
uk sending 600 troops to get british
citizens out of afghanistan as the
taliban continues to take major cities
and edges closer to kabul just hearing
there from uh johnny mercer mp who
actually served three tours of duty in
afghanistan at lashkar has now
fallen he says it's pretty humiliating
for this country that we have withdrawn
along with the rest of the international
community from afghanistan earlier i
spoke to the defense secretary ben
wallace who told me he was increasingly
worried about the situation and further
extremism
i'm absolutely worried that failed
states uh breed uh
our breeding grounds for those type of
people of course i'm worried it's why i
said you know i felt this was not the
right time or decision
to make because of course
al qaeda will probably come back
certainly would would like that type of
breeding ground that is what we see
failed states around the world lead to
instability and lead to a security a
threat to us and our interests we we're
very clear about that that's why the
west has to learn that you don't fix
problems you manage problems you know
you you have to you know go into a
country if that's what you're going to
do and you manage it there's no such
thing as an instant fix which i think
it you know is one of the differences
between the west and many parts of the
world and that's what happens but yes
i'm concerned but we do have
capabilities to protect ourselves even
after leaving afghanistan
joe park with us this morning uh good
morning to you joe's thoughts
i thought that was an incredibly candid
blunt assessment from the defense
secretary of course the situation is
deteriorating very rapidly he didn't
want really to frame the deployment of
600 troops as to reactive responsive
certainly denied that it was a rescue
mission but he was incredibly critical
of that u.s supposed peace deal with the
taliban saying it was rotten he also
conceded that the taliban now have
momentum and as we just heard they're
also saying he's absolutely worried that
failed states are breeding grounds it's
clear that this may be something
happening on the other side of the globe
but it really could hit this country not
just because
he is clearly concerned that al-qaeda
terrorists could effectively uh you know
base themselves there and hurt this
country in the future but also because
of the unfolding humanitarian crisis in
a few months or in a year
certainly people in government feel we
will be seeing the effects of this
perhaps uh increasing people crossing
the channel if pretty hot in the home
office thinks that situation is bad now
it certainly could get far worse and
that is before k
we look at the anger felt by those who
have served in the military in
afghanistan or indeed who have lost
lives over 400 lives lost in the british
military johnny mercer of course as you
heard from saying the situation is
appalling humiliating and heartbreaking
the level of anger is something that ben
wallace is
aware of and i think that's why in your
interview with him he was far more
candid than we usually ever expect from
a cabinet minister indeed so he says
that he wasn't blaming america
but it
it did sound as though he was blaming
america it certainly did he certainly i
don't think he wants to uh criticize the
the by demonstration but far more blunt
in his assessment of what the trump
administration uh has done and i think
there is a feeling that this is all very
uneasy for the uk he he didn't serve in
afghanistan himself but ben wallace has
a military uh background and he knows uh
he knows the the sort of visceral anger
felt uh by people who he knows on a on a
close personal level and that's very
uncomfortable for him i think indeed for
now thanks very much joe um i'll take uh
at nine o'clock with the joe meantime
take a look at the latest developments
in the u.s lawsuit against prince andrew
we'll be talking about that in just a
few moments time
six people dead on the streets of
plymouth will be speaking to the local
mp shortly and
province after province in afghanistan
continuing to fall to the taliban more
on that to come but first prince andrew
is preparing to face a lawsuit in the
united states brought by a woman who
says she was forced to have sex with him
whilst being abused by jeffrey epstein
the duke has refused to comment on the
case but has previously said that the
allegations are untrue
joined now by someone who is interviewed
who's i should say who has interviewed
him a number of times before and that's
joel ellidge who is a senior writer at
the sunday times hello thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
john um how damaging is this lawsuit for
prince andrew and for the royal family
it makes a long
difficult legal process worse for him
but if you talk to those who are close
to the jew they spy a little window
opportunity too they've been anxious for
a while to cross-examine his accuser
virginia dufrey and they see a
possibility that her decision to lodge
this case might give them that
opportunity
there are crunch talks going on at
balmoral as we know right now we saw
prince charles arrive um yesterday his
ex-wife is there his daughter's there
the queen is there one wonders what
impact all of this is having on them not
least because it's a big anniversary for
the queen next year
indeed and it's that's the biggest
question of all of course the damage to
the duke is one thing the damage to the
institution is quite another and the
queen as we've seen recently with other
members of her family um is absolutely
determined that
the institution will be protected uh
above everything else
indeed so so what what does that look
like do you think
he he won't be returning to frontline
duties i'm guessing
wait wait the way it's the way it's
working out now i think the decision is
close to being made that the duke will
have to try
to close the legal case we'll have to
try to find some way to to settle it the
reason for that is if he doesn't the
game of
she said he said oh and by the way
here's a photograph of us together that
will just go on and on and on and on and
that will cause so much damage to the
institution that can't be allowed to
happen so he's gonna have to try to find
some way of putting this
you know putting this case to one side
he only has i think another 19 days to
go um work before his lawyers have to
answer the allegations laid against him
uh in a court in new york you you met
the duke i believe several times but you
have interviewed him as far as i know in
2017 um what was he like tell us about
the man
he has a very generous assessment of his
own intellect which is why he
occasionally does and says things that
aren't very uh
don't turn out very well for him he has
in the past when i think quite badly
advised by some people he has a very
senior team of very accomplished
advisors around him now who are
sitting him down and explaining to him
the predicament he's in and what he
needs to do and if he's smart or smarter
than he was before he's going to listen
very very carefully to them and do
exactly what they say
they are the key if there is any key to
unlocking this problem for him
my viewers would say
we've been hearing about this case for
ages forever and ever and ever and it's
still going on is it coming to a head
now
it's coming to a very important stage
because they are probably going to duke
is probably going to take this
opportunity to
uh try to
reach some accommodation or go to court
or whatever it may be but it's still
going to take quite a long time i think
we're looking at a year or two
and talk to me also if you would please
about i touched on it a little bit
earlier on in the interview about
whether at any stage
um even when he's cleared um he could
return to
public duties or is that it for him now
he's done
he's done if they can't settle this case
that's why they're so focused on it if
they can settle it or at least push it
to one side in some way
as they would see it you know muddy the
waters possibly try to discredit his
accuser in some way if they can push it
to one side then he's got a little
window maybe where the air is clearer
where he can make a fulsome apology for
bad decisions he made before definitely
regretting his association with epstein
and pledging to devote the rest of his
working lives to public service and good
works he's got a bit of an opportunity
there but that can only happen
if he can push the legal case to one
side as long as this legal case goes on
as long as she said he said and this
photograph of the two of them together
with no clarity as to who's telling the
truth he really has no way back that's
why they're so focused on trying to
engage in some way at this point and use
this legal action to try to try to fight
it to try and push it to one side so
that he then has little gap
to move on but it's going to be very
very tough
thanks very much for taking the time i
don't think i've chatted to you before
uh we look forward to seeing you again
very soon thank you very much
thank you thanks a lot talking about the
future for the duke of york uh what
about the future for football it didn't
really come home did it in the summer
but the premier league does kick off
again tonight and for the first time in
more than a year stadia will be full
fans may face random spot checks of
their coveted status at the first few
matches of the season bart covid isn't
football's only problem racism continues
to hang over the game and the players
and fans are under scrutiny shingi
mariki joins us now from brentford fans
ahead of their team's premier league
debut tonight
this is what it means to make it into
the big time
[Applause]
promotion to the premier league comes
with riches prestige and pride
but there was one thing missing when
brentford climbed to the summit of
english football
for most of the season grounds were
empty
that changes tonight is the besotted
pride of west london podcast for die
hard fans of the bees the buzz that
comes with a normal match day in full
stadium have been sorely missed if you
ask me
five six years ago you know would you
see brentford in the premier league
within the next decade i would have said
you there's no chance you know and it's
not disrespect to our team but it's one
of those things it's really hard to get
to it's the night that every every
brentford fan has waited for i guess i
still pinching myself um
it sounds it feels almost unbelievable
but i'm really excited about it and i
can't wait for us to get going
little over a decade ago brentford were
in the lowest tier of english league
football tonight they begin their first
campaign in the top flight since 1947
here against arsenal as minnows in a
league full of giants they'll be hoping
for a fairytale season
the story of this season won't just be
about what happens on the pitch though
there are big questions about how the
sport deals with racism after three
england players suffered abuse for
missing penalties in the euros final
time at a community event surrounded by
potential stars of the future the head
of the competition believes the answer
is a zero tolerance approach
anti-discrimination is a big priority
for the premier league and all of its
clubs um we won't tolerate
uh and discriminated behavior racist
behaviour in our grounds or online if
you are cool using discrimination
language either online or in stadiums
you can be banned not only from your own
club but all premier league grounds
who kick off all 20 clubs will continue
to take the knee but some players
including crystal palace's wilfred zahar
and brentford's own ivan tony have
decided to make their point standing up
[Applause]
beyond that debate and the pandemic this
is how things ended last season the
trophy in the blue half of manchester
with fans back and life a lot closer to
normal retaining that title would be
even sweeter shingi marike sky news
season starts tonight now were you
watching this program yesterday of
course you were well take a look at this
[Music]
that's the pianist composer and
presenter jules holland he was on the
show yesterday explaining how he was
giving the gift of music to support
children grieving the death of a family
member and here he is the moment he did
just that performing a little number
before donating that very piano to the
charity child bereavement uk
[Music]
how lovely a quick look at the weather
fiona
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning the weather still fairly
changeable really over the next few days
signs of something drier next week and
actually for many today there will be
some drier and brighter spells it's a
little bit better today than yesterday
there are still showers around some
heavy and quite blustery through parts
of northern ireland and much of scotland
especially northwest scotland but the
winds although strong here are not quite
as strong as yesterday uh further aside
there'll be a few showers in the west
not many eastern parts looking a little
bit drier up to 23 or 24 in the
southeast so out of the wind actually
feeling quite warm we will keep those
showers going in the very far north as
we head through the evening and
overnight largely dry elsewhere but by
the end of the night thicker cloud
rolling in from the south hawaii
certainly looking wetter for parts of
ireland that rain spreading its way
eastwards as we go through the day on
saturday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways